[Music]
welcome back to harbor unbox today we're
reviewing the new NVIDIA GeForce r-tx
2070 super and r-tx 2060 super graphics
cards and yep they really went with
Super whatever I guess it's just a name
after all so doesn't matter too much and
at least is a clear identifier that
these GPUs are indeed new and different
from existing 2016 and 2017 products
without wasting any time let's jump
straight in the specs and we'll also
discuss the pricing the r-tx 2060 super
is coming in at $400 u.s. so a small
price premium over the existing non
super models for that 14% bump in price
you do get quite a significant upgrade
at least in terms of specs though at
first glance it doesn't appear to be the
case as we are only getting 13% more
criticals however we do see a massive 33
percent increase in ER ops and this
extends the 192 bit wide memory bus of
the original r-tx 2060 to 256 bit wide
for the super version because the same
14 gigabits per second GD dr six memory
is used the bandwidth has also increased
by 33 percent to 448 gigabytes per
second so then the r-tx 2060 super has
the same memory subsystem as the r-tx
2070 and 2070 super and this means it
gets eight gigabytes of vram essentially
then it's a slightly cut-down version of
the 27 t both use tu 106 silicon the 27
t super on the other hand comes in at
the same 500 price point as the 27 t so
it's effectively replacing this part and
you can expect vanilla 27 TS to be
phased out shortly
for the same money you're getting at 11%
upgrade in crew cos 28% more texture
units while the rock count remains the
same we also see a reasonable 9%
increase in Bruce clocks for the core
but given most cards are factory
overclocked this will have little impact
on performance finally the memory
configuration remains the same eight
gigabytes of gddr5 10 gigabits per
second for memory bandwidth of 448
gigabytes per second unlike the standard
27 t which uses two
six silicon the super version has been
upgraded to two 104
the same silicon used by the r-tx 2080
so the r-tx 2060 super looks to be a
rather substantial upgrade over the base
model but you're paying a bit more while
the 2070 super looks to be a similar
upgrade over the 2070 but in that case
you're getting the extra performance at
no added cost I guess it's the extra
memory that in videos stinging gamers
for with the 2060 super finally I should
just note they'll also be a 2080 Super
and that model is going to slot in at
the $700 u.s. price point but right now
other than its existence and the
suggested price we don't know too much
more as the specs and release date are
yet to be announced that said Nvidia did
claim some info claiming it will have 15
and a half gigabits per second GDI 6
memory and it will be faster than the
Titan xp for testing I've used an Intel
Core I $9.99 or ek processor clock at 5
gigahertz with 32 gigabytes of ddr4 3400
memory the latest drivers available at
the time of testing have been used and
all this data is fresh brand new for
this video and collected in the past
week and a half we have a dozen games to
look at and then we'll do the usual
performance breakdowns and look at the
cost per frame data I will be focusing
on the 1440p performance but for all the
Teddy P and 4k results please get them
for free over on our patreon page the
link will be in the video description ok
let's get into the results first up we
have battlefield 5 and here we see the
2070 super bridging the gap between the
2070 and 2080 not a massive performance
boost but not bad either the Radeon 7 is
still 18% faster in this title but it
does cost at least 36% more so I suspect
the 2070 Super is going to cause more
pain for AMD's current flagship GPU
meanwhile the RT X 2060 super looks
adequate I guess it was just 9 percent
faster than the RT X 2060 in this title
while that had at nipping at the 2070 s
heels and ahead of Vega 56 that's not
exactly an exciting result given that it
costs 14% more but I guess there is some
utility in having that extra VRAM this
time when testing with Tom Clancy's
Rainbow six siege the 2070 super is
closer to the 20
than it is to the 2070 and it also
comfortably beat the older GTX 1080i so
a very solid result here I should also
note that it comfortably beat aimed is
Radeon 7 as well the 2060 super was 16%
slower than the 2070 super with an
average of 111 fps and this place - a
little behind the standard 2070
basically between it and the standard
2060 so again not a particularly
impressive result given the increase in
price moving on we have Metro Exodus
here the 2070 super was nipping at the
heels of the Radeon 7 falling short by
just a few frames per second this also
meant it was much closer to the r-tx
2080 than it was the 2070 then we say
the 2060 super outpacing the standard
2060 by 10 percent margin to deliver
2070 life performance this time we're
testing with Resident Evil 2 the 2070
super is again right on the radio and
sevens tail though this time it does sit
right between the 2070 and 2080 the 2060
super is again a smidgen slower than
2070 but faster than Vega 64 so another
10% performance boost over the standard
2060 the 2060 super is a little more
impressive and shut off the Tomb Raider
beating the 2060 by a 13 percent margin
and this made it quite a bit faster than
Vega 64 meanwhile the 2017 super matched
the gtx 980ti and was just a few frames
slower than the r-tx 2080
so a pretty solid result here
fortnight's not a great tunnel for AMD
and we see this here as the 2060 super
is just 5 FPS down on the much more
expensive radio on 7 and we see that
although the 2070 Super was quite a bit
slower than the r-tx 2080 it had no
trouble brushing aside the Radeon 7
beating it by an 11% margin the division
2 results look pretty typical given what
we've seen so far the 2060 super is 10%
fast in the standard model while the
2070 Super is 14% faster than its
standard model this all meant that the
2060 super was faster than Vega 64
while the 2070 Super was faster than the
Radeon 7 the Radeon GPUs do fare much
better in dirt rally - and here the 2060
super is only able to match of agra 64
and was just 5 percent faster than Vega
56 which is
selling for down around $300 us then we
see the 27-year super was just 7% slow
in the Radeon seven so it fares better
in this comparison here we have another
racing simulator in Forza horizon fall
and coincidentally this is another great
title for AMD here we see the radio and
seven streaking ahead of the 2017 super
making in videos new $500 offering 17
percent slower then we see the 2060
super is also done in by Vega 56 losing
by a 10% margin moving onto some fire
cry new dawn testing and here we see the
2060 super right behind the 2070 while
the 2070 super is right behind the 2080
this means the 2060 super was able to
match Vega 64 and the 27-year super was
a percent slower than the Radeon 7 and
yes I am aware that I've said super way
too many times in this video but what's
the alternative the second last game
tested is World War Z and he the Radeon
GPUs performed very well the 2060 super
couldn't keep pace with Vega 56 while
the Radeon 7 was significantly faster
than the 2070 super still relative to
Nvidia Zone practice TAC these new super
versions did perform quite well finally
we have the last game tested Assassin's
Creed Odyssey and here the 2060 super
was 11 percent faster than the standard
2060 which is pretty typical based on
what we've seen so far
meanwhile the 2070 Super was 10% faster
than the standard 2070 and this put it
right on the tail of the 2080 and 1080
Ti so that's gonna do it for the gaming
benchmarks let's move on to check out
power consumption looking purely at the
GPU power consumption we see the 2060
super is very efficient consuming just
5% more power than the standard 2060 and
just 2% or four watts more than the RX
590 then we see the 2070 super jumped up
to 198 watts and that made it 11% more
power hungry than the 2060 super but
still it was considerably more efficient
than the Radeon competition consuming
20% less power than the Radeon 700 once
we factor in the entire system draw
those margins are reduced quite
substantially now the 27 is super
just 10% less power than the Radeon
seven and there are some interesting
changes here when measuring power draw
from the wall Vega 64 jumps well ahead
of the r-tx 20 atti for example and in
the GPU test it did consume less power
the reason for this change is down to
the fact that we're now including the
power draw off the entire graphics card
as well as other components in the
system such as the CPU which has to work
harder when paired with certain GPUs
typically the more powerful models
anyway the super variants slide in
exactly where you'd expect them to in
terms of power usage now moving on into
operating frequencies temperatures fan
speeds and a little overclocking out of
the box the 2060 super found edition
around at 70 degrees with a fan speed of
16 hundred and 50 rpm so it was
virtually silent the GPU maintained an
average operating frequency of eighteen
hundred and fifteen megahertz after an
hour-long loop of the f1 2018 benchmark
overclocked our sample was able to
sustain 2010 megahertz after the
hour-long test and they saw the
operating temperature increase to 75
degrees with a fan speed of 1900 rpm so
a pretty typical 11 percent overclock
for this cheering based GPU moving on to
the 2070 super and we see that out of
the box the founders edition model
picked at just 68 degrees with a fan
speed of 1600 rpm and this allowed it to
maintain an operating frequency of
eighteen hundred and nineteen megahertz
overclocked our sample maintained at
operating frequency of 1980 megahertz
but please note for the first few
minutes of this test it was running at
over two gigahertz but after about five
minutes it did begin to throttle down
and by the end of the hour-long test it
only sustained 1980 megahertz which is a
mere 5% overclock the Kart was only
running at 71 degrees
with a fan speed of just 1700 rpm so it
was still incredibly quiet okay
so there's all the performance
information now it's time to make sense
of it and for that we have a few
performance breakdown charts and then of
course we'll look at the cost per frame
data so let's go do that as you'd
probably expect based on the benchmarks
just seen the r-tx 2060 super is indeed
only slightly slower than the GeForce
r-tx 2070 so for the most part around 4%
slower
the only game where the performance was
equalized was Assassin's Creed Odyssey
while the only game where the margin was
extended beyond 4% was fortnight when
compared to the standard 20 60 the new
super duper version was 9% faster an
average though we are comparing to MSI's
gaming z version nvidia suggests the
supermodel is 15% faster on average but
either way not an overly impressive
result given you're paying 14% more so
it's basically just another cheering
based GPU that fits in on the pricing
structure that was set a year ago we're
still for the 2060 Suba is the fact that
it's just 11 percent faster than AMD's
Radeon rx Vega 56 which can be had for
less than $300 now sure it is on the way
out but at least in the short term
that's not great news for the much newer
NVIDIA GPU moving on to the 2070 super
and here we see on average it was 7%
slower than the RDX 2080 and this
effectively eliminates that part as the
2070 Super is almost 30% cheaper but of
course before too long we should have an
RT X 2080 Super part as well but the
point is at least relative to existing
RT X parts the 2070 super does look like
a pretty good deal still it's not an
amazing deal basically you're getting
12% more performance an average for the
same price not nothing but not amazing
either that said we've come to expect to
these 12-month refreshes by this point
so who's surprised that we're not
getting a 30% performance boost anyway
that is the reality we're faced with
these days but anyway let's move on to
see how it fares against AMD's Radeon 7
well there you have it just 4% slower on
average and given it costs at least 26
percent less the 27-year super
effectively kills the Radeon 7 was never
more than 17 percent slower fair to say
without a price cut the Radeon seven
trillion debt at this point now time for
the cost per frame analysis but before
we look at the current asking price
let's just do an MSRP comparison but
don't focus on this data too much as it
can be a little bit misleading
I just wanted to compare the MSRP sphere
so that shows how much progress we've
made from the Pascal generation here we
see that the 2060 super costs four
dollars and 59 cents per frame and that
makes the gtx 1070 24%
more costly frame and that sounds pretty
good for cheering but remember the gtx
1070 is now a three year old product so
while that certainly is progress it's
not really a lot of progress given the
time period I should note that the 2060
super is 30% faster than gtx 1070 but it
also costs 5% more now for the 2070
super here we sent the gtx 1080i cost
33% more per frame so not a bad result
for the 2070 superb but again not
exactly a super result given we're
comparing it to a now two-year old
product
okay so let's compare the MSRP of the
2060 super and 2070 super to the current
market prices of competing products and
for this I've removed the end of
production pascal parts as new models
are overpriced here we see the 2060
super is still worse value than the
original 2060
in fact even more so here given that you
can now get 2060 models for a slight
discount at $330 u.s. we're still you
can get Vega 56 for just 270 dollars in
the u.s. right now and that makes the
2060 super 35 percent more costly per
frame having said that keep in mind
those Vega 56 deals aren't available in
all regions but even so the fact that
the 2060 super isn't particularly great
value sitting next to even the $400 Vega
64 that isn't good news for gamers
thankfully the 2070 super is better
value than the 2070 but at an 8 percent
discount per frame it's not exactly
cause for celebration still it does one
punch knockout the Radeon seven and rx
2080 graphics cards so there is that and
that does indeed bring us to the end of
this video in videos attempt to steal
aim DS thunder next week seems a bit
weak to me they really could have given
us a lot more but perhaps they don't
need to and I guess that is the real
issue here ignoring AMD's navi and i
guess we we sort of have to given that
we're under NDA and we have cards
sitting on the test bench right now but
ignoring na'vi it's fair to say this
roughly 12 months later refresh from
Nvidia it's pretty underwhelming and it
really wasn't worth getting out of bed
for
and I need as much sleep as I can get
right now the r-tx 2070 super is decent
it certainly kills off the Radeon seven
at its current asking price and
basically does the same to the RT X 2080
so you're almost getting $700
performance for $500 almost not quite
and I suppose that is a bit
disappointing roughly a year later but
there's also no better deal is price
point and that's exactly why we're
desperately in need of a knee to step it
up a notch or two maybe three however
compared to the RT X 2060 super the 2070
super is a much more exciting product
and well I guess that's also very
disappointing price to performance the
2060 super is technically better value
but you expect that with lower on parts
and while its worst value than the
standard 2060 in terms of performance
you do get that extra two gigabytes of
vram the foundation cards did run quite
cool and they were very quiet I also
think they look quite nice and the build
quality is excellent
the good news being this time around you
don't have to pay a premium for the EFI
model so you can get them at the base
MSRP so that is some good news there
overall not much more to say on this one
if you enjoyed the video be sure to the
like button subscribe for more content
and if you appreciate the work we do at
our own box then can see that supporting
us on patreon thank you for watching I'm
your host Steve and I'll see you again
next time
[Music]